In Milgram's study, he obviously could not tell the participants that it was a
study on obedience to authority. Instead, he told them it was a study of
memory. And here you can see the original advertisement that Milgram used. When
the participant arrived, there were always two other people present. One was
Milgram, who was the experimenter and then there was another person. And
Milgram had these two people draw slips to determine whether they're going to
be a teacher or they're going to be a learner. Unbeknownst to the participant
the person who was with Milgram was actually confederate. Meaning that person
was working for Milgram. Therefore, when they chose slips, Milgram had arranged
it that the real participant was always the teacher, and the learner was a
confederate, or a person who was working with Milgram. Now remember the
participant thought this was a study on memory. So Milgram told the participant
that he was going to read a series of words and that the other participant, the
learner, who was a confederate, would have to remember those words. Every time
the learner would get a word incorrect, the teacher was to deliver a shock. The
learner was to memorize those word lists. And provide correct answers. And
during the study Milgram, who was the experimenter, observed the teacher and
provided instruction. So here the teacher thought that he was to read words and
deliver shocks, but in fact Milgram was testing that participants level of
obedience aAs well as his willingness to inflict pain to the learner. Now,
remember the learner was a confederate working for Milgram, and he did not
receive any actual shocks. And he actually didn't even respond to the word
lists. All of the responses were pre-programmed. And finally MIlgram served as
the authority figure in this study and he was positioned next to the teacher
while the teacher was reading the words and supposedly delivering the shocks.
So we had the teacher, the learner and Milgram. Now let's go into a little more
details on the specific methods of the experiment. The teacher and learner were
to be tested in seperate rooms, but before the learner left, the teacher
actually was hooked up to the shock machine and received a very small shock.
And this was to let the teacher know that the shock generator actually worked.
And also so the teacher was aware of the type of shocks that the learner would
experience. Millgram instructed the teacher to provide a shock for every
incorrect response. And, they would start at the low end of the shock
generator. And with each consecutive incorrect response, the teacher had to
provide a shock. And, that went up on the shock generator to 450 volts. So
here's the experimental arrangement. Here we had the teacher, who is sitting in
front of the voltage machine, and notice that the learner is in a separate
room. Remember, the learner is the confederate and when the study began, he
actually just left the room. All of the responses were pre-programmed. Notice,
too, that Milgram was sitting near the teacher as he was observing that person.